will nato be setting up military
infrastructure in finland and sweden
well what we announced yesterday is that
we are upping our presence across the
eastern flank making sure that all of
our allies are secure and this is vital
because we face a much more uncertain
and insecure europe and that is why
we've also seen finland and sweden join
for years and years they remain neutral
but they can now see the very real
threat from russia so what's ended up is
that putin who wanted less nato has now
got more nato but it will be a matter
for
finland and sweden to discuss with nato
exactly how that will work exactly what
is set up in finland and sweden but i'm
absolutely delighted that they are now
on the path to becoming nato members and
they will really help strengthen our
alliance yeah okay so it's not just
being members we are going to see
military infrastructure in place in
finland and sweden as well as rose nato
is concerned we've heard what president
putin has said he says that if that was
to be the case russia would respond in
kind
what would nato do about that
we've heard this rhetoric from putin
about all kinds of plans in the past
so he said that it was a red line for
him
that finland and sweden would join nato
he said it was a red line if uh western
nations supplied weapons to ukraine this
is rhetoric we have to ignore the
rhetoric and instead do all we can to
continue to support ukraine with the
weapons they need to win this appalling
war because if we don't it means that
there'll be much greater threat for
european security in the future today
we've announced an extra billion pounds
of military aid to ukraine to help them
push russia out of their territory and
we have to focus on keeping going
keeping the support going to ukraine
keeping the sanctions on russia and
really ignoring
the rhetoric from vladimir putin what
matters is what happens on the ground
but the rhetoric is now ratcheting up to
cold war levels during the cold war um
our spending in the uk was five percent
of gdp
how much more would you like to see an
increase of the spending as a percentage
of gdp here in the uk
well our spending is currently 2.3 of
gdp we've put an extra 24 billion pounds
of spending in yesterday or today we
announced the extra billion to support
ukraine what we now need to see is our
allies and partners step up because the
figure you quoted k
is a figure for nato overall some
partners are still not spending the two
percent i see the two percent as a flaw
it's a minimum and we need to make sure
that we're all contributing and making
sure that the uh defense and deterrence
is much more effective
than
what we have seen for the past 20 years
which i fear has enabled uh putin to
carry out this appalling war
okay so ben wallace and the defense
secretary saying he's looking for more
come the middle of the decade and then
the next spending review would you agree
with him
i agree that we need to make sure that
all of the western alliance is spending
more on defense and putting more into
particularly to supporting
our eastern allies i'm not going to get
into details of the negotiations of the
spending review
i think it is imperative that we do
make sure that our defense budget is fit
for purpose and also you're able to deal
with the modern challenges like cyber
warfare uh the issues that we face in
space as well
okay is it fit for purpose
we are
so we we're following through on the
integrated review that we put together
last year
we are focusing on what uh what we need
to supply across the board
we have been at the forefront of support
to ukraine uh we are the
first european country to send weapons
to ukraine but of course we continue to
need to support them in the future to
make sure that they win
and that they prevail over russia yeah
but going into the last election and the
government felt that the manifesto
pledge should be that defense spending
uh continues at 0.5 percent above
inflation that's not going to happen is
it
well i don't think anybody anticipated a
global pandemic and i don't think
anybody anticipated
that we would be facing a huge economic
uh
shock
uh in the shape of
huge inflation right across the world so
we are in extraordinary times but given
we're in those extraordinary times we
continue to focus on our defense that's
where we're able to provide this extra
billion pounds worth of funding to
ukraine and it's why we've put 24
billion pounds extra into the defense
budget but you won't go as far as the
defense secretary saying that he's going
to be looking to the chancellor and the
prime minister at the next spending
review for a significant increase
well as i've said we we're all
negotiating our budgets for the next
spending review i've been very clear
that the entire free world the western
alliance does need to focus more on
deterrence we need to focus more on
defense and what we know is prevention
is better than cure the
lesson that putin learnt from under
spending on defence was that he could
invade a sovereign nation and we simply
can't that we can't let our guard down
again we can't allow that to happen
again
prime minister says that the army is the
right size uh the leader the head of the
army says it isn't what would you say
i i would say that we need a full range
of uh of capabilities to deal with the
threats that we face now whether those
are cyber threats whether those are
land-based threats naval threats and we
have the balance right but of course we
need to continue to evolve because we're
seeing
you know we never expected in our
lifetimes to see this kind of war
on
in in europe and do you know we have to
cut off ten thousand troops is my
question
i i support our plans on defense
but what i'm saying is we need to
continue to evolve them
as
we face new and different threats and i
don't think any of us
expected to see
this type of war on european land in our
lifetimes okay
i'm not sure you answered my question
but there we are the defense secretary
has called vladimir putin a lunatic with
small man's syndrome the pm says he's
stupid and crazy how would you describe
him
well what i would say is that he is
he has ordered the most appalling crimes
to be committed
in ukraine
we've seen
this systematic rape of women
we've seen the attacking of civilians
including
at the shopping center last week and
what we need to make sure is not only
are the ukrainians successful in pushing
russia out of ukraine but also that
people are held to account
for these appalling crimes that have
been committed how would you describe
him
well i would describe him as a
appalling dictator perpetrating
a
a war that was neither legal nor
justified in any possible way
of sound mind
i've not met vladimir putin i do not
know
the motivations for
carrying out this appalling war all i
know
is that we have to make it our absolute
priority
to stop this war to push vladimir putin
and the russian troops out of
ukraine otherwise we will live in a much
less safe europe talk to me about the
commons foreign affairs select committee
um
they say that uh your department was too
slow to impose sanctions on russia and
clamp down on corrupt russian money
being laundered in the uk in other words
dirty money was being laundered and your
department should have done more about
it and they were too slow to act how
would you respond
well we have sanctioned as a country
more individuals and entities in russia
than any other government in the world
we passed emergency legislation as soon
as
this appalling war was perpetrated as
soon as russia invaded ukraine and we've
been able to
hit russia hard with sanctions
most recently we
sanctioned russian gold and we're
working with our allies across the world
to do that and the uk has led on this it
was back last year in liverpool at the
g7 that we agreed with our allies that
there would be severe sanctions if putin
invaded ukraine we've followed through
on that and we've delivered the biggest
package of sanctions of any country yeah
but the report goes on to say it was
shameful that it had taken a war the
ukraine war for ministers to introduce
the economic crime act
we acted as soon as we could to deal
with the appalling consequences of the
war in ukraine and our priority is
cutting off the funding that putin is
using to perpetrate this war and that is
why it's very important that we
end the purchase of oil we end the
purchase of gas from russia we're
encouraging our european allies to do
that because ultimately that is what
will cut off funding for the war machine
and what i'm focused on as foreign
secretary is making sure that we have
the effective means of stopping this war
so you don't accept the criticism from
the committee
i don't we acted very quickly and we
have done more than any other country in
terms of the number of individuals and
entities we've sanctioned okay harriet
harman um is going to be or is indeed
chair of the privileged missy which will
be looking into partygate and whether
the prime minister lied to parliament or
not ben wallace defense secretary
yesterday told me that he didn't see a
problem with that what do you think
i don't see a problem with that either
but the committee clearly has to uh take
its course and make its judgment
as i've said before i'm 100 supportive
of the prime minister and what people
want us to be doing in britain is
getting on with the priorities
working to make sure this appalling war
in ukraine is ended
getting the economy going after the huge
shock of covert and that is what we are
focused on type that's what we're
focused on as government ministers so
you don't share the anxiety shared by
some apparently conservative mps well
conservative mps apparently sharing the
anxiety that
that it's going to be a kangaroo court
and it's not fit for purpose
no we have these processes in parliament
it's the process has kicked off we now
need to wait for the result
do you think the prime minister
should um just bite the bullet and go
for a snap election he won't rule it out
what do you think he should do
as i've said we are focused on
delivering for
the british people we're facing the
worst war in europe for decades we've
got the
aftershock of the pandemic which is
having huge effects around the world on
inflation on people's incomes on
economic growth we are spending our time
focused on dealing with those challenges
not speculating about elections so it
shouldn't be until 2024.
others said we're not thinking about
that we're thinking about getting on
with the job you're not running it out
then there are you foreign secretary
well i'm i'm i'm focused on getting on
with the job there is a lot to be done
uh making sure that the ukrainians have
all they need to deal with this
appalling uh invasion by russia making
sure that we help our allies
particularly our allies on the eastern
front and the eastern flank who face
who face threat from russia making sure
that we deal with the longer term threat
of china as well you know that is what
i'm spending my time on
okay we must let you go madam foreign
secretary thank you very much indeed for
joining us thank you